china is going to exert an incredible
amount of influence
they already are they're actually
already bragging about it
if it turns out this way if the trump
legal team
is not able to overcome all of the
nefarious powers allayed against them
look a lot will have been accomplished
within four years i hope more can be
accomplished in the future
we will have to be grateful for the
memories this is something
that should have us all holding out hope
until the very very last minute
that president trump can somehow eke out
an election victory here i don't i still
don't think there's any reason to
concede before the electors vote
we should all be holding out hope
because it's not just joe biden though
he's probably the greatest example of
this
for decades elite politicians in this
country
have sold us out to china they've done
it because they have a stupid political
ideology
that tells them that rising china is
good for the world that's why they let
the china into the world trade
organization 20 years ago it's why
they've allowed china to steal our
intellectual property that's why they've
allowed china
to violate world trade organization
treaties that's why they've allowed
china to illegally subsidize their steel
and aluminum and
manipulate their currency the list goes
on and on and on and on
most importantly they've allowed china
to steal our jobs
and the the argument for it is oh it's
good for the world if china
gets more economic power they'll
liberalize their country they'll become
more democratic they'll become more like
america and that'll be good for
everybody
obviously that hasn't happened the other
reason is that china's just buying
direct influence
you saw this with the hunter biden
scandal you've seen this with other
american politicians
we now have experts on communist china
admitting
this kind of influence there was a
recently recorded lecture
showing a chinese communist party expert
explaining
how china has quote people at the top of
america's core inner circle
this video has been leaked made its way
onto the internet and into the united
states
after it was censored in china the
person
giving this lecture is dee dong shing
he's vice dean of the school of
international relations at remnan
renmin university my chinese is not
great but my ability to read subtitles
is take a listen to this
we know that the trump administration is
in a trade wars
why can't we fix the trump
administration oh
things were resolved in no time like a
couple do with their quarrels we fixed
everything in two months
what's the reason i'm going to throw out
something a little explosive here
it's just because we have people at the
top
at the top of america's core inner
circle of power and influence
now we know which people he's talking
about here notably he's talking about
biden who's given speeches about this
he's given speeches about how great it
is to empower china
he's gone on the record but you've heard
all the other kind of liberal
establishment people talking about this
as well
this sort of admission is so
explosive that i didn't believe it
actually this video was going all around
the internet yesterday i didn't believe
it
but mainstream news outlets not many of
them but some of them
are are reporting on this because they
have to because this is real
this is a real guy he really is the vice
dean of this ir school
and he's really talking about influence
chinese influence in the united states
hostile powers have often exerted
influence in the united states
right now i'm i'm reading witness by
whitaker chambers it's one of the books
that
turned reagan from a liberal into a
conservative it's from an ex-communist
who details in painstaking detail
all of the soviet influence in the
united states during the 30s
during even even a little before that
and during the 40s
guys who were at the very tippy top guys
who were helping to establish the united
nations
guys who were in the state department
guys who were in the justice department
who were communist
spies and they had that soviet union had
that for a long time when people
make fun of mccarthyism where they make
fun of the house on american activities
committee
we all that's like the punch line now
for a lot of people what that fails to
acknowledge is
these guys were right i mean joe
mccarthy was a little bit of a flawed
individual in the way that he carried
these things out no question about it
william f buckley jr founder of national
review wrote one of his first books
defending joe mccarthy because the
central thesis here
that the soviet union had communist
spies at high levels of the government
was obviously true we know this we know
their names we know the name alger hiss
we know we know people who were
whitaker chambers called this out
mccarthy i suppose called this out nixon
called this out
all made fun of all mocked all have been
sort of written out of the
history of that era but it happened and
it's happening now
with china he goes on
now that we're seeing biden was elected
the traditional elite the political
elite establishment
there are a lot of deals in all these
who helped hunter biden build the
foundation who do you think
who do you think china
this this guy points out very astutely
that wall street
used to exert a lot of influence in the
united states
and then after the financial crisis
2007-2008
wall street lost a fair bit of their
influence and they were sort of the bad
guys because they plunged us all into
this global recession
still the establishment was playing
along and then you had trump
and trump comes in and he offered a
radically different
policy at the domestic level but also at
the international level
don't forget from bush one
maybe even further back than bush one
but certainly from bush one clinton
bush ii obama the president's changed
the parties changed but the foreign
policy
more or less stayed the same didn't
change all that much
our attitude toward china didn't change
at all really
it kept getting nicer and nicer and
softer and softer
then trump comes in and he says no what
are you guys doing
people make this mistake they think
trump was elected because of his
personality because he said some mean
things and made fun of mika brzezinski's
face
not so donald trump offered a different
policy agenda than did the other
republicans in the primary and then did
joe hillary clinton and i suppose joe
biden too
it was a different agenda specifically
with regard to our greatest
geo-political foe
this will be coming back if joe biden
becomes the president
okay this is going to raise a lot of
security issues when we think about
national security we're always talking
about the middle east or you know
terrorists coming over here
a far greater security issue will come
from china there is
no reason to play nicely with china
china views us as an enemy and an
adversary
and there is a political elite in the
united states now led by joe biden
that wants to deny that adversarial
relationship
got to keep security on our mind you
don't need to just take this lecturer's
word for it we now know
about a chinese spy program that was
going on in the united states
that infiltrated very high levels of
government and that specifically
infiltrated the democratic party
and it infiltrated actually this was a
bigger risk
because one of the people that this
chinese spy christine
fang targeted and and infiltrated
was eric swalwell and apparently this
woman is accused
not just of raising lots of money for
these people getting in their circles
she even slept with some of these
elected politicians now
we're not sure if she slept with
swalwell but you'll remember during eric
swalwell's brief presidential campaign
he said that he is us
i am you that was one of his slogans
which means
that i may have slept with a chinese spy
which means i'm going to have a lot of
answering to do to sweet little alisa
except that it means sweet little alisa
will also have slept with the chinese
spy
so frankly i don't this is raising a lot
of questions and a lot of feelings and
emotions that i don't want to get into
this is a family program
but in any case that is the allegation
here
christine fang targeted up-and-coming
local politicians in the bay area
and across the country who had the
potential to make it big on the national
stage
so you know we can make fun of eric swoe
all we want and i think it's a fun thing
to do but the guy did make it to
congress which is kind of low level for
the federal
uh government but still made it to
congress it's a national position
and he was a briefly at least a
presidential candidate so hey that's
something he's a young guy
he's kind of a joke and a goofball but
hey anyway
he made it pretty far and this woman
targeted him when he was
very very local she just saw that there
was some promise here
she did this to other politicians but
first of all well she raised money there
was networking
and there is an open question as to
whether or not there was
a more intimate relationship
for her sake i have to hope she didn't
didn't have to talk about
making a sacrifice for your country talk
about taking a difficult job
if your job requires you to jump in in
the sheets with eric swalwell
but this sort of stuff happens when it
became clear that
she was exerting some influence the
intelligence agencies in the united
states
approached swalwell and said hey listen
this lady looks like she's
a spy he did cut out cut off
relationships with her
other politicians appear to have as well
when she realized she was being
surveilled by the united states
she hightailed it back to china so it's
pretty clear that she was a spy
there are other chinese spies in the
united states that's we all spy on each
other
all all the governments of the world spy
on one another
the question is how successful are they
and beyond espionage what kind of
influence are they exerting
i'm sure the united states has spies all
over the world but what kind of
influence do they have
behind the scenes certainly some we know
china's exerting a lot of influence
[Music]
you